I have a quick question start things off
when you is it true or not true that you
created Hamilton to be able to sign an
exclusive contract with Disney did not
you know I don't think anything in
Hamilton and my performance in Hamilton
prepares you for a childlike wonder
or innocence in any form Hamilton's a
bastard who cheats on his wife and gets
shot at duel but the what's funny is
that mallanna sort of came along around
the same time in it and a certain point
I was playing Hamilton and writing Moana
and those are pretty good opposing
muscle groups to have Moana sort of
saving the world while I was getting
shot nicely and Knightley was was a nice
sort of yin and yang well I mean when I
was thinking about it I'm like you had
that you have this you're doing a little
mermaid I'm like so do you work with
anyone else or is it just Disney now no
I've got lots of lots of different ties
but what's what's sort of crazy about
Disney is that my interest in musicals
really sort of exploded when Sebastian
started singing to Arielle saying the
human world it's a mess
life under the sea is better than
anything we've got up there I something
about that moment sort of changed my
chemical makeup and I think that's
pretty much the reason I started writing
musicals well it's funny I wanted to ask
us at the end but I'm just gonna ask it
now what does it mean to you knowing
loving that material and actually
writing original songs for that movie
like that's crazy well we'll see if it
happens you know I sort of I'm signed on
to Little Mermaid in a fan capacity you
know I'm a producer but basically it's
like if it doesn't need a new song I
don't write it so I'm working with alan
menken if we find a moment that calls
for new song I will write lyrics for him
but you know no one thinks that score is
more perfect than I do so I might be to
Reverend I might talk myself out of a
job right talk about one of the things
that I found they always say in movies
don't work with animals don't work with
kids but the kids in this movie are
phenomenal and so what is it like
working with because one of the kids
hadn't really ever worked before can you
sort of talk about sharing the screen
yeah and I'll give you an easter egg too
because you guys are you guys love that
stuff at Collider
watch joel who's the youngest one in the
music hall scene there's a scene where
they're all holding cotton candy well
jewel doesn't know you're not supposed
to eat the cotton candy between every
take so he basically had a thing of
cotton candy for every take of that and
when they introduced Mary Poppins he is
out of his mind high on sugar he
literally is making faces that no child
has ever made it's it's pretty great and
frankly they were our touchstones
because this movie is all about sort of
revisiting that inner child seeing life
through the eyes of a child and we had
three kids who were going through it so
that's all my character research right
there is watching these kids go through
this experience my last thing Emily
called Rob the silent assassin because
he'll come up and I guess like you're
nervous to do something but he'll just
whisper it to you and say you're gonna
be great can you sort of talk about that
sure I mean Rob is sort of he he
basically makes you feel like you can do
anything and then you force yourself to
because you're like Rob believes I can
do this it's such a simple and generous
way of directing but he really it's you
really feel like oh my gosh this whole
thing depends on me and Rob if Rob
Marshall believes I can do it then maybe
I can't it's it's it's it it's the
opposite of the like isolate and tear
down and build back up again that some
directors belong to it's all love and
generosity and you just want to give him
everything because because you trust it
with it
you